be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books
this one one of my earlier videos we had
a discussion on the villain apocalypse
regarding his publication history that
is to say when he first appeared why he
was made and so on while the initial
video focused largely on how apocalypse
came into the world and how he initially
learned of his abilities we didn't spend
a whole lot of time chronicling his
actions throughout history instead we
kind of jumped forward with this first
appearance an x-factor followed by his
future endeavors and so what I want to
do here is jump back and talk about this
I want to cover the life of apocalypse
from his full origin of until the time
when he first appeared an x-factor issue
number 5
so the origin of apocalypse is given to
us in the story rise of apocalypse
written by terry cavanagh and drawn by
adam Polina the story opens with
apocalypse as he was discovered by a
group of nomads called the sandstorm
errs with the tribe led by a man named
Baal apocalypse after having been found
abandoned by his former tribe was given
the name in Sivan or while the
real-world translation in various
languages comes out to be some variation
of the morning light in Marvel Comics
the name means the first one
continuing with the story the philosophy
of the sandstorm errs as it had been
passed down for generations was akin to
the Spartan sin that only the strongest
were fit to be part of their society the
philosophy of the sandstorm errs became
an ingrained part of apocalypse in that
the story jumps forward to his rite of
passage as part of the Sam summers
belief in the survival of the fittest
the young men of the group would engage
in a battle to the death on their 17th
birthday as a means to prove their role
in the tribe those who survived were
forged in battle and those who died were
considered a weakness one that would
have spread to the tribe had they been
allowed to live while apocalypses
physical appearance was shunned by many
of the young men that were raised
alongside him
this combined with balls clear
favoritism shown towards apocalypse
garnered him a great deal of jealousy
and hatred and so when the battle began
rather than it being every man for
himself it was all of the young men
versus apocalypse without hesitation and
without mercy
apocalypse demonstrates both cunning and
proficiency and cutting down his fellow
tribesmen as a result with his role in
the tribe established Baal leads
apocalypse to a hidden cavern where we
learn both balls reason for adopting
apocalypse as well as a bit of history
involving the sandstorm errs at some
point in the past these Sam summers
existed as a clan that was large in
numbers during this time a ship in the
form of a sphinx appeared in the sky and
crash-landed with a piece breaking off
investigating the severed section of the
ship and finding a survivor the
sandstorm errs took him in and nursed
him back to health
however once he was restored the visitor
who is revealed to have been the
time-traveling villain Kang the
Conqueror uses advanced weapons to
conquer Egypt place himself in the
position of Pharaoh and enslave the
sandstorm errs however with the location
of his ship lost to him came torture the
sandstorm errs for this information but
when none of them revealed its location
can order their executions and while
most of the sandstorm errs were killed
some of them were able to escape and so
with Bal established as their leader
these survivors roamed the lands of
Egypt constantly avoiding Kang's
watchful eye
what Baal also reveals is that among the
various inscriptions in the tomb is the
face of Apocalypse himself apocalypse
reasons that if his own face is among
the various hieroglyphics carved into
the ship then it stands to reason the
king seeks to capture him for his own
ends while this is largely speculation
on behalf of apocalypse his guesswork is
proven to be correct when Kang sends his
generals and armies to the location of
the sandstorm camp with apocalypse Inbal
away the arrival of king's army results
in a massive battle one which results in
the deaths of everyone fighting but
furthermore the battle above causes a
massive cave-in leaving apocalypse and
Baal trapped inside and so as the week's
pass while apocalypse demonstrates a
lack of need for food and water ball
does not and so after Baal succumbs to
death due to starvation and thirst
apocalypse swears vengeance against Kang
and is ultimately able to break himself
out of the cavern from here the story
transitions to Apocalypse working as a
slave during one of his work sessions he
takes a break while pondering his
actions and his intention of killing
Kang as a result he draws the attention
of Kang's top general a man named
Ozymandias when apocalypse addresses
Ozymandias by name he's actually kicked
from the top of the pyramid as a
punishment with the expectation that he
will end up dying
however apocalypse has a vision of the
Sun goddess Isis who informs him that
he's actually meant for a greater
destiny than to be a slave to men and in
the process bestows him with a vast
amount of power now whether this is
actually the goddess Isis or an illusion
has never truly made clear but I would
go as far as to argue that the
is simply a mental manifestation of
apocalypses abilities regarding
telepathy telekinesis flight strength
and immortality
now while his demonstration of his
powers inquire the other slaves to
attempt an uprising
Ozymandias and his forces are actually
able to quell the rebels but are
distracted by another incident which
allows apocalypse to be taken to safety
under the care of Nephi the sister of
Ozymandias as time passes while
apocalypse never reveals his face in
every in addition to his efforts and
showing her the various secrets of cane
the conqueror as well as proof the king
is actually a time traveler he also
begins to develop a romantic interest in
her but when their various quests lead
them directly into a trap set up by
Ozymandias ek the face of apocalypse is
forcefully revealed where he's actually
shunned by an F reforest physical
appearance as a result while he does try
to fight against King and Ozymandias
he's overwhelmed by Kang's advanced
weapons and so he's presumably executed
however apocalypse doesn't actually die
here and instead he makes an effort to
rescue Nephi from her imprisonment but
much like the sandstorm a tribe and the
various slaves he had encountered over
the course of his life never he is
unable to cope with apocalypses physical
appearance and as a result believing
himself to be destined and alone
apocalypse lashes out starting a
conquest from the royal lands in Egypt
and killing all those of royal blood now
in the panic of the conflict came the
Conqueror flees back to his own time and
Ozymandias tries to escape by taking
refuge in what's left of kingship but
when apocalypse arrives after having
harnessed his new abilities he uses his
vast powers to enslave Ozymandias
turning him into stone and forcing him
to operate as a scribe and Oracle for
the rest of eternity
so following apocalypses rise in egypt
he begins traveling throughout the world
encountering a vast amount of primitive
societies with a sandstorm which
philosophy of survival of the fittest as
his mantra apocalypse forces these
various societies against one another
and an effort to prove which
civilization is stronger and by
extension destroying what he perceives
to be the weak civilizations for this
reason throughout the Marvel Universe in
dealing with most ancient earthbound
societies like the Inhumans virtually
all religions at some point or another
indicate the worship or acknowledgement
of some variation of Apocalypse and
however during his travels he comes into
contact with a celestial ship while the
time frame is not really given here what
we're told is that apocalypse is given
an offer by the Celestials apocalypse
can use their vast technology for its
own ends but at some point in the future
a repayment will be required which may
cost his life or perhaps even more the
other half of this is that apocalypse
can refuse their offer and never gain
access to their technology and choosing
to accept apocalypse begins the process
of trying to communicate with the
celestial ship over the course of
several years now during this time there
eventually comes a point at which
apocalypse is met with the arrival of a
being that's referred to as the traveler
now while the identity of this person
isn't initially revealed during their
first encounter the travelers later
reveal to be cable while the paradox as
it exists between both cable and
apocalypse has been explored in other
videos that I've made and that the
future actions of apocalypse lead to
cables appearance in the past their
battle leads to apocalypse gaining
access to celestial technology by way of
cables own blood now using this
augmented ability apocalypse is able to
interact directly with the ship allowing
him to augment himself granting a whole
new plethora of abilities including the
power to alter his own atomic structure
as well as use any physical superhuman
power with these new abilities
apocalypse once again continues his
quest to promote strong individuals and
societies as an example in 1039 ad he
encountered the Thunder God Thor while
Thor is not able to defeat apocalypse
initially after placing an enchantment
on the battle ax yon Bjorn Thor is able
to cut through the
armor of apocalypse and by extension
send apocalypse into hibernation in
order to recuperate
now while apocalypse continues his
pattern over the course of several
hundred years by creating his own band
of agents in the form of the Dark Riders
the most popular creation outside of any
of his horsemen was the creation of mr.
sinister initially a man by the name of
Nathaniel Essex mr. sinister had been
obsessed with the idea of human
evolution while mutants did exist during
this time in the 1850s most of these
individuals were identified by their
physical differences from normal humans
and in response were usually isolated or
else just simply kept in prisons using
this as a way to attain these mutants
for genetic testing mr. sinister
eventually found himself coming face to
face with apocalypse now this is
particularly important because this
actually gave apocalypse meaning and in
truth would actually be the driving
force behind his actions going forward
prior to his encounter with mr. sinister
apocalypse had wanted to believe that he
was the beginning of a new generation of
being but because he had yet to
encounter mutants he had been leaning
towards the idea that he was alone in
his evolution this combined with his
desire to see the expansion of enhanced
people in order to ensure only the
strongest occupied the earth was
guaranteed when he used his celestial
technology to provide mr. sinister with
powers of his own including
shape-shifting immortality and
telekinesis when following this
apocalypse continued his furious
encounters around the world which
eventually led up to his initial
introduction with x-factor issue number
5 with that being said we're going to go
ahead and bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it and I will
catch you guys later peace